c'était comment parc à fouras pas raska
grâce à ça ok on va commandes tard
craint parce que voilà ma grand mère
elle avait très peur et ma mère et nous
sortait toujours devant la porte pour
convoyer l'orage et nous enlever la peur
d'argent c'est le premier réalisateur
français avec kev avec qui j'ai
travaillé donc tard que les grèves
ratera j'en peux plus j'ai tourné des
films aussi de la france déjà chaque
fois on galère pour y aller c'est pas
possible
plus décret dar k moi j'ai beaucoup
l'hiver c'est beaucoup stark a aussi moi
je le ferai pas parce que je trouve que
c'est pas mon ma tronche mais mais voilà
j'ai beaucoup d'émissions le sarca même
si je n'ai pas beaucoup subi mais mais
bon les gens s'aiment c'est bien tard
qu'à moi j'ai une tourte à bulles basse
et les années 80 90 et c'est mes années
de bonheur l'italie sera aussi un sommet
de la méditerranée des très jolies
villes
moi j'adore l'été dernier s'est fait des
voyages à 30g pas où j'aime pas du tout
je mange pas et je mange très bien
d'ailleurs
eldar cas c'est pour moi c'est une de
plus les émissions de la télé française
par rapport au tableau les lumières tout
et voilà obligés de la faire
je peux pas dire des choses mauvaises et
/ ou sur une de mes émissions
les tapas et d'arcade je vous invite
kangourous les tapas espagnoles